[Music]
brothers and sisters and dear friends as
you guys know i'm returning this car
right above me
next month to his rightful own inshallah
ram mercedes they said 650 pounds i was
nearly doing backflips and put them on
the floor
until i did a uh instagram post and
shout out may have blessed these
brothers
they go in contact with me nearly half
the price and better price inshallah
maybe they can even give you a discount
what do you guys do we do servicing well
basically it's just basically an
approved mercedes
safety service and anybody work with
anybody with problems yeah brother what
we do we still we have the body shop
here
yeah we approve photoshop as well yeah
carry out the web to the highest
standard yeah insurance approved
i have all my qualified technicians in
there body workers so we can we do our
own mixing
spray booth high high tech engineering
everything in there
inshallah get the people to come brother
sisters i had a little damage there and
you know they're gonna replace the whole
mirror the brother said look we're just
going to polish it
inshallah check them out i've got the
links at the bottom inshallah mark it
thank you before we start the roman
sisters don't forget to support our work
insha'allah at the link below don't
forget to donate
make dua and share this video with your
friends and family that's very important
for us too but we're going to find out
if he was more than a fight there was a
lot going on there was like there was
strategies in place
let's get into it was it this particular
fight
i came back for the law of this to come
and shoot this man up
a little rat a little weasel a little
hard man in groups
i've met many of them through my years a
man who grows
in numbers but on his own and when
confronted
in a similar situation cowers away and
that's what you saw with that little
on the bus over there he his jokes at
the
other they were something to his own
country man and that nothing got to do
with anything
and that's it i came back for the love
of fighting at the global war and this i
am going to truly
truly love putting a bad bad beating
on this little glass jaw rat
habib there's a time where you and
connor were pretty cordial with each
other i'm almost friendly
fanboy the man was a fan boy he bought
t-shirts of mine
he supported the cars you remember that
your little fanboy
your little fanboy he bought t-shirts to
support the cars nothing but respect
and then and then over on his neck of
the woods a man involved in something
who was actually he was now in prison
but vladimir putin locked him up from
business
150 million worth of money from the
russian russian people
started to invest and pump money into
his gym so he started to grow in power
started started gaining this false power
i started thinking he was a little hard
man tough guy
then did the farmer jump on he gets
locked up and there was not a being left
and now here you have to put the nail in
the coffin that's how it began he was a
fanboy
toy was a little hard man after a while
with some money like many people do
money and numbers now the money's gone
the numbers are still there but trust me
his his own countrymen his own people
that he's that he's turned his back on
they want to see him gone too
and i am going to do it in the name of
the russian people
you know over here do you think
sometimes you know when i was watching
that it's like
you know when you know your opponent
let's say for example if i'm fighting an
appointment opponent yeah
and i'm a bit like
doesn't fit in there yeah let's say it's
in a point at which he's a boxer yeah he
knows he's more
i seem as like you know his experience
now
i know that if i feel like that i'm
going to try to get one over him
psychologically
do you get it so i think that's what's
happening because he's going very
personal man it's like he's done
research he's gone he's talking about
stuff that's political man yeah there's
no doubt that he's done research i mean
you saw uh sorry
you saw that there's one point at this
uh press conference where he makes
reference to
ali
and he makes very very specific
reference to the guy
yeah but his family life and said to the
extent you think if he
knows this information he's done he's
got a team behind him yes
i think personally um people are reading
a bit too much into it obviously
he's clearly done his research yeah he's
mentioning all this stuff about cadillac
150 million into a gym and the guy being
invested money and go i don't know if
that's true or not
but clearly he has done some research
and he's trying to get one up in in the
press conference
but personally i don't think it's
working yeah where are you watching
what do you think look at the psychology
of those two men would you
how at this moment but don't you think
there's a bit of like
insecurity on gregor's side it's very
loud i don't know he's always like that
but it's just like something different
about him this time
i would always say something different
from the beginning when he said i came
back for love with this i don't think he
came back for the love of it i think
he's
pretty smart he came out to promote his
his whiskey
yeah that's what i think he brought the
button out he also cops
all of that that song and dancing about
it but um
the way i see habib is very calm
mcgregor's i think he's just trying to
get into his head
yes personally he's trying to make him
angry trying to make him lose focus
trying to do the same thing he did to
aldo if you see what he did to aldo aldo
undefeated
world champion for 10 years and uh
when i just made them totally bugged so
i think i think there's a bit
it's a bit similar so the battle is not
only in the ring that's what we
are definitely not maybe if you have any
response to what conor
said this is everything what i expect
in in terms of what what what did you
expect like what
the truth because that's all i talk what
are you talking about
that's all i talk truth yeah i'm coming
here for
smurfs these guys i trust me mate i
smash
i don't wanna yeah smash
location here he is right here